[Music]
you know Brad Pitt is also trying to
keep the world out of his business the
actor had his lawyers back in court
today as he tries to stop all the leaks
of personal information from his custody
battle with Angelina Jolie a lot of
people are saying that
Angelina's airing this out just the
Democrats reputation is there any
comment to that I will not make any
comment ten o'clock this morning
that's Angelina's lawyer Laura Wasser
leaving court after Brad's team called
an emergency hearing to basically say
quit airing the family's dirty laundry
in public I think anytime you end up in
court that's probably not a great sign
how come this wasn't filled in the first
place can't comment so what made Brad
fighting Matt the legal custody
agreement documents that Angie filed
publicly Brad's team feels that violated
the confidentiality clause ét news
producer Tracy Kaczynski was inside the
courtroom family law specialist Steve
Mandel has analysis so the curious
question is why did Angelina file this
document skeptics would say she filed
this because she wants to damage brad
pitt's celebrity and increase her
celebrity but the truth of the matter is
Angelina believes that Brad might
violate the order and she wants to be
able to move quickly and efficiently the
judge denied Brides request for an
emergency hearing he'll likely have to
wait until January for a judge to decide
on that but he'll really need that time
to go through the motion which is more
than a hundred pages long based on the
new court papers Brad asked to see the
kids the week after Thanksgiving
Angelina reacted hit is seeking more
time with the children but he and Angie
clearly can't come to an agreement and
look at this
Brad requested that between now and the
holidays
he gets 30 to 60-minute therapy sessions
with his children he specifically asked
for one session with the twins won with
Shiloh and Zahara one with all four and
one with pax and Maddox but if the boys
don't want to participate Brad wants
time with the
for is there any indignant light to this
coming up zone or my hope is that with
big upcoming holidays things will come
down a little bit will they be together
for the holidays I don't believe that
you